is it true we're gonna have to wait  until 2024 for season three i think that  might be true i honestly don't know  there's some executives that know better  than me you might want to ask them  probably no you might have to wait 10  years you got to co-write and co-produce  a special episode is that something you  would want to revisit for the third  absolutely i mean sam has a very  particular way of working so i'm not  sure if that exact sort of format would  ever happen in quite the same way again  do you think cat is ready for a  relationship in season three no i don't  think anyone's ready for a relationship  in euphoria but that doesn't mean they  won't be anyone you got to tune in to  find out baby i don't want to give too  much away